an abc 6 news reporter named miles
harris had a very hilarious surprise
when he was preparing for a shoot in
columbus ohio when his mom decided to
interrupt him by driving her car
right behind him i've never had this
happen to me but i've been on set with
my mom while i'm trying to perform and i
lose i can
i can do anything you want in front of
strangers what did she do she
she came on she's very nervous
but i personally can't perform in front
of family members because i get very
very nervous i got it i had the first
time that my uh my brother invited my
brother and sister on to ytv to do
something
and i just in my head it was like oh
it's gonna feel like a regular day we're
gonna do our little sket uh excuse me
all those sketches it'll be fine
but when they were there witnessing how
i act yeah and how i am with my
co-workers and also what i do for a
living it was a very strange experience
i felt myself being a little bit out of
body
thinking about what they were thinking
about so that's my problem i care so
much about what my family thinks that
like i get my own head and mess myself
up there you go yeah well then we gotta
invite your folks here
have them sit on the couch over there
offset i can talk cars with your dad and
then you can be nice i'll do that for
you i'll do that so my dad could
then talk about you for literally the
next 10 years and say that carlos guy i
like him like literally that would be my
dad all right take a look we'll see you
back here next time bye bye
it's my mom hold on
hi baby
i'm trying to work right now you're over
there calling my phone this is the
angelo you can say hi
and don't be holding up traffic cause
you got cars behind you
[Music]
did you record that